Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Nur 76 Tage nach seinem Amtsentritt schmeißt Jos Luhukay schon wieder hin beim VfB Stuttgart. Ich frage mich, was ist da los? Und ich reiche diese Frage weiter an den freien Sportjournalisten und Stuttgart-Kenner Stefan Rommel.
Stefan, wie läuft die Frage? Frage gleich beantworten, hallo.
Ja, geh mal voll rein.
Na ja, also was ist da los? Na, es hat sich jetzt schon angedeutet, die letzten Tage, dass da ordentlich was im Busch ist und dass es womöglich, wenn die nächsten ein oder zwei Spiele nicht gewonnen werden, dass dann Konsequenzen zu erwarten sind, aber dass es jetzt so schnell geht und der Trainer dann von sich aus aufgibt. Gut, das war vielleicht auch ein bisschen eine Option, aber dass es jetzt tatsächlich so hoppla hopp geht, war dann ein bisschen überraschend. Und die eigentliche Trennung finde ich nicht.
Okay, lass mal von vorne anfangen, denn du bist tief beim VfB Stuttgart drin. Bei mir ist er ein bisschen aus dem Fokus gerutscht. Und auch wenn ich sehr schätze, wie vehement der VfB Stuttgart sich als Thema in den Rasenfunk drängt, auch als Zweitligist, stehe ich einigermaßen ratlos da. Luhukay kam im Sommer und für mich sah das von außen betrachtet nach einem Wechsel, aus dem man schon mal machen kann. Also es gab den Kalschlag, Bobic weg, ja schon vorher weg, dann Kramny weg, Doth weg, genau, den meinte ich. Den meinte ich, genau. Und dann kam Luhukay. Das sah für mich von außen betrachtet okay aus. Mit dem Trainer kannst du definitiv aus der 2. Liga in die 1. Liga aussteigen, auch mit den vorhandenen sportlichen Gegebenheiten. Aber was ist da denn jetzt dann schiefgelaufen, dass wir nur 76 Tage später einen Trainer haben, der vollkommen entnervt hinschmeißt nach einem durchwachsenen Saisonstart?
Du hast noch einen vergessen. Das ist der Präsident, Bernd Waller. Der muss ja auch gehen. Das ist wichtig in dem Zusammenhang, weil tatsächlich dann im Juni, Ende Mai, Juni war da das totale Vakuum. Also es waren quasi nur noch die drei Aufsichtsrats, Chefstar, Jänner, Schäfer und Port. Und sonst war eigentlich keiner mehr da.
Das sind ja alles, die nichts mit Fußball zu tun haben, oder? Der eine ist von Wirth, der Chef.
Wirth, Kercher und Daimler AG. Also das sind Leute, die aus Weltunternehmen bzw. aus mittelständischen Unternehmen kommen. Die sollte man annehmen Ahnung davon haben, aber vom Fußball offenbar jetzt nicht so viel. Was jetzt? Gut, jetzt im Nachhinein muss man sagen, ein großes Problem gewesen. Eine der ersten Maßnahmen war ja dann Kienle, Mark Kienle, den ehemaligen Jugendtrainer und Thomas Hitzesberger als sportliche Berater dazuzuholen, um das, was ihnen immer dem Verein vorgeworfen wurde, dass die sportliche Kompetenz fehlt in den Gremien, um das quasi ein bisschen aufzuarbeiten und besser zu machen. Aber da ging es dann schon, da ging es dann schon los mit den ersten Fragen, so ja, was sollen die denn jetzt genau machen? Das Jobprofil von Kienle ist klarer definiert als das von Hitzesberger und mittlerweile, nachdem dann noch zwei, drei andere Leute installiert wurden, unter anderem eben Luhukay und dann später auch Schindelmeiser, weiß momentan keiner so genau, was der Thomas Hitzesberger da jetzt machen soll, wie oft und muss er da sein oder kann er das von München aus machen oder wie auch immer. Also das ist auf jeden Fall, der Grundgedanke war gar nicht schlecht, aber die Umsetzung war halt eher nicht so gut. Halb gar. Ja, so kann man es auch sagen. Also es hat halt so ein bisschen den Anschein, so aktionistisch jetzt was, ja, jetzt haben wir ja was gemacht, jetzt wird ja dann alles gut und jetzt kann uns erstmal keiner mehr was vorwerfen. Das große Problem in der Luhukay-Schindelmeiser Sache meines Erachtens war, dass ja Luhukay deutlich früher da war. Also Luhukay war da, als tatsächlich gar kein anderer da war, der irgendeine sportliche Kompetenz hatte.
Das heißt, wer hat Luhukay dann geholt? Der Aufsichtsrat. Der Aufsichtsrat und da waren die sportlichen Berater noch nicht am Board.
War ja sonst keiner da, war ja sonst keiner da und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie sich dann darauf großartig verlassen hätten, weil, wie du vorhin schon richtig, wie ich finde auch bis heute noch eigentlich angedeutet hast, ist Luhukay natürlich eigentlich schon ein sehr guter Trainer, um mit einer ordentlichen Mannschaft in der 2. Bundesliga den Aufstieg zu schaffen, was er ja glaube ich drei Mal vorher schon geschafft hat, mit Gladbach, Hertha und Augsburg. Genau. Also das ist erstmal, hätten jetzt, wenn du jetzt 100 Leute fragst, hätten 95 gesagt, ja ist ein guter Mann, für einen Aufstieg passt. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, inwieweit Luhukay sich da jetzt so frei bewegen konnte in der Zeit, wo halt gar kein anderer da war und sich dann vielleicht auch schon bestimmte Gedanken gemacht hat und bestimmte Konzepte für sich selber entwickelt hat und so weiter, die dann aber mit der Installation von Schindelmeiser, es war ja klar, dass ein neuer Sportvorstand kommen muss, also Schlagstichsportdirektor, die da vielleicht auch torpettiert wurden. Jetzt, wenn man sich heute die PK von Schindelmeiser angeguckt hat, da war das schon sehr bestimmend, finde ich. Und er hat auch gesagt auf die Frage, wann er denn gemerkt hätte, dass es da Probleme geben könnte mit Luhukay, hat er gesagt, ganz ehrlich, nach dem ersten Gespräch. Und das ist natürlich schon eine saubere Ansage. Also, da kann jetzt erst mal keiner von den beiden was dafür. Das gibt es ja öfter mal, dass zwei Leute nicht miteinander können. Die Frage ist ja aber, wie kommt jetzt das Gremium dazu, zwei solcher Leute einzustellen? Also, ich muss mir da vorher Gedanken machen. Das sind dann jetzt, weil einen Präsident gibt es ja immer noch nicht, es sind jetzt die zwei wichtigsten Leute in meinem Verein, wenn ich mich nicht selber so wichtig nehme, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Es sind die zwei wichtigsten Leute in diesem Verein und die müssen halt miteinander funktionieren. Es gibt immer mal wieder Ausnahmen, wie in Hannover vor ein paar Jahren mit Schmatke und Slomka, die halt einfach auf einer geschäftlichen Ebene so la la funktioniert haben, da war auch Sportliga folgter, aber halt so sonst miteinander nichts zu tun haben wollten. Aber das ist, finde ich, die totale Ausnahme. Gute Bundesliga- oder Profiklubs zeignen sich dadurch aus, dass die drei Leute, die da was zu sagen haben, Präsident, Sportmanager oder Sportdirektor und Trainer vor allen Dingen, dass die drei miteinander funktionieren und dann läuft der Laden. Also das jetzt verkürzt dargestellt. Und das, also um dieses Grundprinzip so arg zu verletzen, das ist der ganz große Fehler, der jetzt natürlich auf den Aufsichtsrat zurückfällt. Also ich finde, man kann jetzt, klar kann man jetzt sagen, Luhukay, der ist mit Sicherheit kein einfacher Typ, der ist auch stur. Schindelmeiser kann ich schwer einschätzen, weil er so lange weg war vom der Bildfläche. Der ist aber auf jeden Fall offenbar sehr klar in dem, was er vorhat und was er für Ansagen macht. Das ist okay, aber ich kann da nicht von vornherein sagen, ja das wird jetzt schon irgendwie gut gehen mit den beiden, weil jeder ist in dem, was er da in seinem Bereich gut genug ist, um mit dieser Mannschaft wieder aufzusteigen und dann aber nach Stunden oder Tagen zumindest zu merken, ja hoppla, das funktioniert ja überhaupt nicht. Also die hatten vor drei Wochen in Düsseldorf 1-0 verloren und nach dem Spiel hat der Luhukay im Prinzip fast nur auf der Banken des Spiels und da gab es tatsächlich sehr brenzlige Szenen, Elfmeterszene für Düsseldorf, die dann zum entscheidenden Tor geführt hat. Die fragwürdig war ganz am Schluss noch eine Elfmeterszene, die eigentlich für den VfB hätte geahndet werden müssen, mit der Chance zum Ausgleich in der Nachspielzeit. Und da gab es danach viele Interviews mit Luhukay und Funkel, dem Trainer von Düsseldorf. Und normalerweise gehst du davon aus, dass der Trainer jetzt, der gerade unterlegen ist, aus dem Sattel geht, dass der da jetzt ein bisschen Druck macht, dass der sich beschwert. Und dann steht der da und erzählt in Seelenruhe, so als ob er jetzt gerade mit dem Funkel am Dresden steht und vielleicht ein Bier bestellt. Also so wirklich auf einer ganz, als ob die jetzt Kumpels wären und so halten sie jetzt halt so ein bisschen über Fußball. Und da habe ich mir zuerst mal gedacht, das ist ja echt eigenartig.
kennt man Luhukay ja auch gar nicht.
Ja und nein, aber er kann schon auch aus der Haut fahren. Gerade wenn er sich ungerecht behandelt fühlt und da in dem Spiel hätte man das durchaus so sehen können, dass das nicht ganz gerecht war. Aber der hat das einfach so hingenommen und da habe ich mich zuerst mal gedacht, okay, das finde ich jetzt eigenartig, aber da war ja die Länderspielpause, dann der Sieg in Sandhausen, der Fußballer ist natürlich auch grottenschlecht, war wirklich grottenschlecht und jetzt halt am letzten Freitag eben das Spiel gegen Heidenheim, das eine absolute Offenbarungseid war auf ganz vielen Ebenen und da eskalierte das ja dann danach, unmittelbar auf der Pressekonferenz danach, ist es ja dann das Ganze eskaliert und dann auch so wirklich an die Öffentlichkeit getragen worden, dadurch, dass die beiden sich quasi völlig konträr zueinander geäußert haben. Öffentlich, genau. Also der Trainer hat auf der PK was erzählt von, Spieler sind noch nicht so weit, die können das noch nicht spielen, deswegen sitzen die draußen und Schindelmeiser sagt fünf Minuten später, es ist Aufgabe des Trainers, die jungen Spieler heranzuführen und dann funktioniert das schon. Also jetzt sinngemäß. Genau, das war halt klar, was Sache ist und dann, wie gesagt, ging das jetzt hopp, hopp, am Montag, glaube ich, war das, stand dann auf einmal zu lesen, welche Spieler Luhukay denn angeblich bevorzugt hätte, wobei ich bei dieser Geschichte echt ein bisschen vorsichtig bin, weil man ja dann auch weiß, intern in so einem Verein, wenn man sich dann quasi drauf verständigt hat, dass einer zum Abschluss freigegeben ist, dann steckt man sowas halt einfach auch mal durch. So eine Info, die jetzt schwer zu verifizieren ist, außer von dem Beteiligten selbst, also von Luhukay selbst, wenn er jetzt wirklich gesagt hätte, ja, das stimmt, ich wollte Ronny haben von Hertha BSC und ich wollte Marco Marin wurde da genannt haben, dann würde ich das auf jeden Fall glauben, so bin ich mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher, ob das jetzt nicht einfach eine Sache ist, die halt dann denjenigen, wie gesagt, der Invisier ist, noch schlechter dastehen lässt als er vorhin schon war. Natürlich, jeder sagt ja, super, Schindelmeiser, super gemacht mit solchen Spielern, kannst du nichts anfangen. Also zumindest nicht auf Dauer. Ich glaube halt auch, wenn man jetzt aufs Inhaltliche schon mal gehen mag, Schindelmeiser hat natürlich, muss natürlich eine gewisse Mittelfristigkeit im Blick haben. Deswegen hat er ja auch Spieler geholt, von denen es dann, also jetzt gegen Ende der Transferperiode, wo es dann hieß, die wollte Luhukay ja gar nicht. Den Asano, den Pavard, den Innenverteidiger und den Flügelspieler von Lissabon. Alles junge Spieler, die noch ein bisschen entwicklungsfähig sind, von denen man vielleicht in zwei Jahren oder in drei auch noch was erwarten kann. Und wenn du dagegen jetzt stellst, Marco Marin zum Beispiel oder Ronny, die hätten halt kurzfristig gut funktionieren können, aber das ist halt nichts, worauf du was aufbauen kannst.
Ja, ich meine, die Mischung macht es auch vielleicht. Luhukay weiß natürlich auch, wie du aufsteckst und er weiß auch, was ein Team in der zweiten Liga erwartet.
Absolut.
Vielleicht hätte man sich in der Mitte treffen können. Ich meine, das sind jetzt alles drei Namen. Also ich kenne da jetzt nur die Namen und die sportlichen Biografien, aber da sage ich jeweils, genau wie du, ja, cool. Ist halt quasi mit auf Zukunft gedacht. Aber es ist ja auch legitim für den Trainer zu sagen, ich möchte da noch Leute mit reinmischen, die ich auch mal bei 0 zu 1 in der 89. Minute gegen Düsseldorf reinschmeißen kann oder so ein Kram.
Absolut richtig. Also ich will mich da jetzt auch gar nicht auf eine Seite schlagen. Ich sehe die Notwendigkeit auf beiden Seiten gegeben. Allerdings widerspricht sich Luhukay natürlich auch in gewisser Weise. Also er kann ja nicht behaupten, die neuen Spieler, die jetzt seit knapp zwei Wochen da sind, die wären noch nicht so weit. Das kann er in seiner Expertise als Trainer natürlich sehr gut einschätzen. Aber er kann ja dann nicht den Leuten im Gegenzug verkaufen wollen, dass einer wie Ronny, der glaube ich zwei Spiele gemacht hat letztes Jahr, dass der denn jetzt auf Anni funktionieren würde. Das kann er nicht sein. Also das halte ich für einen totalen Widerspruch. Und da hat er sich auch nicht schlau verhalten, finde ich.
Ja, vor allem ist natürlich die Frage der Konfirmationswege. Du kannst das halt nicht öffentlich machen. Also das musst du beiden Seiten eigentlich vorwerfen. Selbst wenn die das im ersten Gespräch merken oder gerade wenn sie das schon im ersten Gespräch gemerkt haben, gehen wir einfach mal davon aus, es war für beide relativ früh klar, wir vertreten unterschiedliche Interessen. Dann musst du eigentlich in der Offseason, sag ich jetzt mal, einen Weg finden, damit auch umzugehen, oder?
Also nochmal, also das letzten Freitag dann nach dem Heidenheim-Spiel, das war dann halt die Eskalationsstufe nach außen, die sehr wahrscheinlich intern schon längst gezündet wurde und da war es dann schon zu spät und im Prinzip dann, wie man jetzt auch weiß, nur noch tatsächlich eine Frage der Zeit. Wobei ich – und da muss ich jetzt dann nochmal auf Luhukay gehen. Ich habe mir auch alle Spiele natürlich angeguckt vom VfB, inklusive Pokalspiel. Das war natürlich echt super dünn bis jetzt. Also wirklich super, super dünn. Zwei Siege, wie vorhin schon mal erwähnt, Hans Sandhausen spielerisch echt schwach, durch zwei Standards gewonnen. Ist ja legitim, aber es geziemt halt nicht einem Verein wie dem VfB Stuttgart. Das reicht halt dann meines Erachtens nicht aus, sich darauf zu verlassen. Das Heimspiel gegen St. Pauli noch gedreht, da konnte es zur Halbzeit 3-0 für die anderen stehen. Dann ist das Ding durch. Und dann halt Düsseldorf. Okay, das ist ein bisschen doof gelaufen. Das fand ich eigentlich noch fast das beste Spiel. Und dann Heidenheim war wirklich, also das war wirklich katastrophal. Zu Hause 1 zu 2 vor 55.000 Leuten, genauso wie St. Pauli auch. Das war natürlich schon echt sehr, sehr schlecht. Und da muss man sich schon fragen, wie wenig Fortschritte diese Mannschaft, in der er doch relativ lang Sommerpause gemacht hat. Und es waren ja auch, natürlich haben viele Spieler den Verein verlassen, das ist völlig klar. Aber es sind ja immer noch überdurchschnittliche Zweitliga, also Spieler, die über dem Zweitliga-Niveau anzusiedeln sind, sind ja noch genug da. Nur, und da, jetzt komme ich nochmal aus, ein drittes Mal auf Luhukay zurück, dann müssen die halt auch spielen. Also dann kann ich nicht verstehen, dass bei fünf Pflichtspielen, die absolviert wurden, so ein Spieler wie Maxim viermal auf der Bank sitzt. Der saß viermal auf der Bank, selbst im Pokalspiel und hat nur in Düsseldorf angefangen. Und dass eine Innenverteidigung zusammengebastelt wird aus Sunjic und Sama, die letztes Jahr schon beide gezeigt haben, dass sie offenbar, wie man sich jetzt darstellt, noch nicht mal ein ordentliches Zweitliga-Niveau haben und spielen trotzdem jede Woche. Also die machen ja Sachen und das kann einfach nicht sein, dass er das nicht sieht. Kann nicht sein. Da muss es andere Gründe dafür geben. Die wissen wir nicht, weil es auch keiner weiß, was mit Maxim genau ist. Aber nicht nur, weil er jetzt das Spiel gegen St. Pauli gedreht hat, sondern weil es tatsächlich so ist, dass es eigentlich fußballerisch in dieser Liga, in der 2. Liga, gibt es keinen besseren Spieler als den. Und ich finde, da muss der spielen. Und ich kann auch nicht die ganze Zeit einen Sean Zimmer im Mittelfeld spielen lassen, der ein super rechter Verteidiger ist für eine Mannschaft, die sauber nach vorne spielen mag, weil der ständig Dampf macht und marschiert. Und stattdessen spielt der Kleine rechts hinten. Und der Zimmer ist im Mittelfeld meines Erachtens völlig verschenkt. Und das sind halt lauter so Sachen, wo ich mir dann denke, ja, wieso macht der das? Und wieso macht er das jetzt schon wieder? Weil das hat im Spiel davor schon nicht funktioniert. Wieso spielt er nicht mit zwei Angreifern? In der zweiten Liga, wo die Innenverteidigungen alle nicht so besonders sind, bei einer Mannschaft wie Stuttgart, die im Prinzip in jedem Spiel Favorit ist und das Spiel machen muss, der kann ja auch mal mit zwei Stürmern spielen. Macht er nicht. Spielt mit einem Stürmer.
Also hat sich Luhukay sportlich sehr angreifbar gemacht?
Ja, finde ich schon. Die haben jetzt zwei Spiele verloren und zwei gewonnen.
Ja klar, Platz 9 nach vier Spielen ist jetzt nicht so gut.
Ja, Platz ist egal. Platz ist egal. Du musst gucken, was die anderen Mannschaften machen. Braunschweig hat eine geile Truppe beieinander dieses Jahr. In zwei Wochen ist Heimspiel gegen Braunschweig. Wenn es jetzt ganz dumm läuft, dann sind die neun Punkte weg nach sechs Spieltagen. Das ist eine Menge Holz, finde ich. Also jetzt sind es momentan sechs, aber ich gehe eher davon aus, dass die in Stuttgart gewinnen, als dass der VfB gegen Braunschweig gewinnt.
Also sportlich alles andere als überzeugend. Dann das große Manko, die Differenzen wurden öffentlich ausgetragen. Ab der Heidenheim-Niederlage, die ich auch – ich habe das Spiel nicht gesehen, aber nicht zuletzt, weil ich das bei Kicktip vorher tippen musste, habe ich mich da sehr gewundert über diese Niederlage. Und ab dann ging es ja auch richtig hoch her. Also dann kam quasi dieses Öffentliche dazu. Und jetzt weiß man eben Dinge, die dann klar wurden. Das heißt, es gab Differenzen bei Transfers. Wie ganz genau wird man die erfahren? Aber zumindest hat Schindelmeiser gesagt, diese drei Spieler, die du vorhin genannt hast, die wollte er nicht haben, die jungen Spieler. Und dann kann man sich überlegen, was Luhukay wahrscheinlich sonst anstelle haben wollte. Aber – und da kann man ja eigentlich fast sogar argumentieren – ein Glück, dass das jetzt nach dem vierten Spieltag schon, weil es nicht geklappt hat, so diese Differenzen aufgebrochen sind und sich das trennen konnte. Weil das sieht ja nach einer vollkommen unmöglichen Kombination aus. Nicht auszudenken, wenn der VfB jetzt drei der ersten vier Spiele gewonnen hätte. Oder?
Ja, da ist durchaus was dran. Also, und nochmal kommt die Geschichte um den Präsidenten jetzt nochmal mit dem Spiel. Am 9. Oktober ist ja Mitgliederversammlung und da ist jetzt vom Aufsichtsrat ein Kandidat berufen worden. Der Herr Dietrich.
Das heißt, es gibt ja keine richtige Wahl.
Es gibt keine Wahl schon, weil der muss ja bestätigt werden, beziehungsweise gewählt werden, aber es gibt keinen Gegenkandidaten, der Alternativen bietet oder eine Alternative zumindest bietet. Das ist schon mal schlecht von vornherein. Und dann kommt noch dazu, dass der Herr Dietrich zwei, wie soll ich sagen, zwei Makel hat jetzt in Anführungszeichen. Erstens war er bei Stuttgart 21 involviert, was per se, ob das jetzt gut ist oder schlecht, oder auf welcher Seite er war, ist ja egal. Aber es heißt halt automatisch schon, dass die Hälfte der Leute in der Stadt oder in diesem Umfeld mit diesem Mann jetzt eher weniger anfangen können. Und zweitens kommt dazu, dass er wohl durch Beteiligung und eigene Firmen in einem Geflecht mit verstrickt ist noch, dass gemäß Satzung des VfB ihn eigentlich gar nicht in berechtigte Frage kommen lässt, diese Präsident zu werden. Das ist eine sehr verschobene Geschichte. Einer seiner Firmen ist wohl unter anderem bei Stuttgarter Kickers mit dabei und versorgt die halt auch monetär. Und da geht es dann schon los. Und es gibt natürlich auch die DFL-Statuten, die einzuhalten sind. Da bin ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt überfragt und bin auch gar nicht so genau im Thema. Ich habe das nur mitbekommen, dass es da unter Umständen jetzt auch ein bisschen Stress geben könnte, dass der Herr Dietrich da vielleicht am Ende gar nicht aufgestellt werden kann. Also auf jeden Fall, um es kurz zu machen, am 9. Oktober ist Mitgliederversammlung und die könnte einigermaßen unterhaltsam werden. So oder so.
Du hast mal über Rasenfunk gesagt, und das war glaube ich schon, das dürfte schon vor anderthalb Jahren gewesen sein, sehr früh, da hast du, als wir über die sportliche Situation von Stuttgart geredet haben, hast du gesagt, ja, aber grundsätzlich stinkt der Fisch vom Kopf her und es herrscht keine Unternehmenskultur und es reden zu viele Menschen mit, die sportlich vielleicht nicht die ausgewiesene Kompetenz haben. Und wenn ich mir jetzt das alles vor Augen hole, und vor allem die Tatsache, dass er ist der Trainer und dann der Sportdirektor geholt wurde, und in meinem Verständnis nach müsste es genau umgedreht sein, denn der eine ist der Boss vom anderen und der eine macht die langfristigen Strukturen und der andere muss es umsetzen für die A-Mannschaft, das zahlt doch total auf dein damaliges Argument ein.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gut zusammengefasst. Ob da jetzt viele oder wenige Leute mitreden, ist ja erstmal nicht so wichtig, wenn erstens alle, wenn sie richtig sind, und solange dann alle in dieselbe Richtung laufen. Aber es kann ja nicht sein, dass drei Leute nach links laufen und fünf nach rechts. Und deswegen, also der ganze Verein ist dermaßen, hat sich dermaßen selber ins Chaos gestürzt und begreift einfach nicht, wie er selber tickt. Das check ich einfach nicht, dass die das nicht kapieren, dass es nicht von allein, oder wenn ich jetzt ein oder zwei Leute einfach mal hole und dann auf die hoffe, dass es dann nicht funktioniert. Ich habe es heute irgendwo gelesen, der VfB hat die letzten 7 Trainer, also in den letzten 3 Jahren 7 Trainer. Und diese Trainer hatten eine durchschnittliche Arbeitszeit von 16 Spieltagen. Das ist ja absolut lächerlich. Und da kannst du irgendwann auch gar nicht mehr hergehen und die einzelnen Entscheidungen auseinander pflücken. Weil es gibt ja immer einen Grund, warum dann Stevens kommen musste, 5 Spieltage vor Schluss oder sowas. Die Gründe gibt es immer. Die entscheidende Frage ist ja, wie sieht eigentlich jetzt genau, in der Wirtschaft würden sie wahrscheinlich sagen, die Wirtschaftsleute, die da im Aufsichtsrat sitzen, wie sieht das Assessment Center aus? Also nach welchen Kriterien stellt ihr denn bitte schön, welche Leute für welche Posten ein? Das ist meines Erachtens die absolut entscheidende Frage. Und es war ja nicht nur so, oder ist ja nicht nur so, dass dann Trainer ausgetauscht wurden, sondern halt auch in der Zeit drei Sportdirektoren und zwei Präsidenten und der Dritte steht vor der Tür.
Und Sportdirektor Dutt hat sich angekündigt mit einer Pressekonferenz, wo er quasi gesagt hat, kein Stein bleibt auf dem anderen, ich werde mich daran messen lassen. Musste er dann auch und musste gehen, aber da hattest du natürlich auch schon wieder wilde auch Richtungswechsel drin mit der Entlassung von Zorniger hin zu Krabbendie und so weiter.
Ja, ist ja okay. Also das war ja auch gar nicht so verkehrt. Vielleicht war die Tonalität die falsche. Die war ja damals, die wurde ja angepeilt. So ist es ja nicht. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass da keiner hingeht und sagt, ich mache jetzt hier einen Jahr lang und dann gehe ich wieder, sondern dass da jeder eine Idee hat.
Ja, aber da muss man das noch ein bisschen aushalten. Ich meine, Zorniger ist jetzt ein Spezialfall, aber andererseits ist es so, so kann man sich natürlich immer bei jedem Trainerwechsel rausreden, dass es ein Spezialfall war. Zorniger ist, ja. Also wenn man sich für einen Weg entscheidet. Also das Gegenmodell dazu ist ja der Werderweg, den ich witzigerweise aber gerade in der letzten Schlusskonferenz auch kritisiert habe. Vielleicht bin ich auch einfach ein Mekka-Typ. Aber wenn man sich für einen Weg entscheidet, dann muss man doch auch bereit sein, dafür die ersten Schritte, die tun halt meistens weh. Und es kann halt auch so sein, dass die ersten Meter auf einem Weg aussehen wie ein Rückschritt und erst dann kommt die Kurve und es biegt sich um. Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen poetisch gesprochen, aber es wird halt auch ständig, also diese 3 und die 5 Leute, die in unterschiedliche Richtungen drängen, die kriegen ja aber auch ständig den Ball zugeworfen. Es ist nicht so, dass wenigstens die 5 mal für 2, 3 Jahre die Richtung bestimmen dürften. Und wenn dann der Kahn im Dreck steht, dann sagen die 3 anderen, ok, gut, jetzt müssen wir aber wirklich unseren Weg einschlagen.
Absolut. Also die Konsequenz ist ganz radikal gedacht. Aus meiner Sicht müsste sein Aufsichtsrat entlassen, abwählen. Der wurde ja eh schon die letzten Jahre bei den Mitgliederversammlungen nie entlastet. Ich glaube beim letzten Mal waren es fast drei Viertel der Leute, die dagegen gestimmt haben. Das sagt auch schon einiges aus. Erstens das und zweitens braucht der Club einfach, du hast das vorhin unternehmens, der braucht eine Leistungskultur. Der braucht wirklich auf jeder einzelnen Ebene in dem ganzen Laden muss eine richtige Leistungskultur her. Das geht los beim Hiwi auf der Geschäftsstelle und hört auf beim Top-Verdiener im Kader. Und das kann einfach nicht sein. Und davon haben ganze Generationen von Mannschaften in Stuttgart gelebt, die haben noch nicht mal den Vertrag unterschrieben, dann stand da schon das Auto auf dem Hof. Das geht nicht. Das kann so nicht funktionieren. Und weil du gerade eben Sonniger angesprochen hast, oder den Knackpunkt, ich finde, das war tatsächlich ein Knackpunkt, wo es in die richtige Richtung hätte gehen können, das hat man hier auch schon ausufernd oft besprochen. Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, dass die Trennung falsch war damals. Es gab natürlich absolut stichfeste Gründe dafür. Trotzdem, wie du gerade eben schon gesagt hast, vielleicht hätte man das jetzt einfach auch mal aushalten sollen und sagen sollen, hey, wisst ihr was? Natürlich mag das ein verschobener Typ sein und der kann mit den Medien vielleicht nicht so gut, aber hey, das ist mir doch scheißegal. Wenn der dann nachher die Mannschaft auf Linie bringt und wenn es 15 oder 17 Spieltage dauert, der Weinziel hatte mal 9 Punkte oder 11 mit Augsburg nach der Vorrunde, bis nach Drüben, dann muss man das halt einfach auch mal aushalten, weil wir haben uns für diesen Trainer entschieden und dann ziehen wir das halt jetzt auch mal durch. Aber so viel Geduld ist offenbar, beziehungsweise so viel Durchhaltevermögen ist offenbar dann zu viel verlangt, oder? Ich weiß auch nicht. Es ermüdet halt die Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen und vor allen Dingen deren Herzblut da dranhängt. Dieses ewige Hamsterrad von und wieder neuer und wieder neuer, das ermüdet halt unglaublich.
Ich habe heute gelesen, noch 100 Tage bis Weihnachten oder wie der VfB Stuttgart-Fan sagt, noch drei Trainer.
Ja, das raubt halt Glaubwürdigkeit. Also selbst von den Leuten, von denen halt die meisten noch nicht mal die Namen wissen, geschweige denn, dass die da irgendwas zu sagen haben. Aber dann heißt es halt nur, ja, also irgendeiner muss ja da sein, der dann ne Entscheidung trifft. Und die ist halt wirklich in regelmäßiger, in schöner Regelmäßigkeit offenbar die falsche. Beziehungsweise so gewählt, dass sie nicht dauerhaft sein kann. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Aber dann lass doch mal genau in die Zukunft gucken, weil das würde mich interessieren. Es gibt meiner Meinung nach zwei Baustellen, die sind unterschiedlich schwierig zu lösen und auch unterschiedlich schwierig für uns einzublicken. Und ich finde, das eine ist quasi die politische Baustelle, dass du im Verein, im Aufsichtsrat, in den entscheidenden Gremien mehr Leute bräuchtest, die eine Sportkompetenz haben und die vielleicht auch den VfB Stuttgart ein bisschen anders verstehen und dann eventuell auch besser. Und die andere Perspektive wäre die sportliche, wo man sagen kann, ok, welchen Weg würde denn wahrscheinlich Jan Schindelmeiser jetzt einschlagen? Lass mal erst mit dem vielleicht ein bisschen schwierigeren anfangen. Gibt es denn überhaupt im Stuttgarter Umfeld – man hat ja da immer so bestimmte ehemalige Vereinskorrifälen oder besonders andere große Unternehmen – gibt es dann überhaupt Leute, wo du sagen würdest, mit denen im Aussichtsrat könnte da was anderes anfangen? Von welcher Kategorie sprechen wir denn da?
Es gibt ja schon auch Leute, die eine sportliche Vergangenheit haben, die in den Gremien sitzen. Also Guido Buchwald ist mit dabei, Hermann Ohlicher ist Ehren – ich weiß gar nicht – aufsichtsrat, irgendwie sowas. Aber damit ist es ja nicht getan. Das wollte ich ja vorhin schon mit der Hitzesberger Sache andeuten. Dann müssen die Leute halt – erstens müssen die was können und zweitens muss ich denen vertrauen und die dann auch machen lassen. Sonst hat das ja alles überhaupt keinen Wert. Nur einen zum Frühstücksdirektor mäßig da hinsetzen und den drei Mal in der Woche da nach Kancha kommen lassen. Das bringt ja keinem was. Also das ist das Erste. Die anderen Sachen, wie gesagt, also es ist auch meines Erachtens egal, ob da jetzt im Umfeld irgendwelche Algeübers, die schon mal da waren und dann auch mal wieder nicht, oder Förster, der schon mal da war und dann mal wieder nicht, oder der Hansi Müller, der schon mal da war und dann mal wieder nicht. Das ist gar nicht so wichtig. Es gibt auch Leute, die gut genug sind, so einen Verein ordentlich zu führen, die keine Sekunde Bundesliga gespielt haben. In Bremen sind jetzt witzigerweise auch wieder zwei, oder mit dem Trainer dann sogar drei Leute da, die Werder-Vergangenheit haben. Und trotzdem meckern alle darüber. Und meines Erachtens auch völlig zurecht. Mit Skripnik, mit Baumann und mit Bode. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt… Der Weisheit letzter Schluss. Aber dann gab es einen Mann wie den Ruhm Schröder, den sie schlauerweise geholt haben, um eine Kaderplanung zu machen. Der ist jetzt in Mainz. Und der wird in Mainz einen tollen Job machen. Garantiert. Aber so einen Mann musst du halt auch mal holen, bzw. holen wollen. Und nicht im Dezember 2014 Robin Dutt ausgraben, der zwei Wochen vorher noch gesagt hat, er muss unbedingt wieder Trainer werden, weil er jeden Tag das Gras sehen mag, wenn er auf dem Trainingsplatz steht. Und 0, 0 Kompetenzen als Sportdirektor mitbringt, außer, dass er beim DFB war, was eine völlig andere Sache ist. Also da fällt mir einfach dann auch mal der Mut, das zu machen. Und dann, wenn sie mal mutig waren, wie damals mit Thomas Schneider, der auf Labardia gefolgt ist als Trainer, und es fängt dann an zu stottern, das einfach dann auch mit durchzuziehen. Aber es werden ja auch abseits von den Profisachen auch, oder wurden ja auch Entscheidungen dann getroffen, die einfach schwer nachvollziehbar sind. Da werden Jugendtrainer, die müssen dann gehen oder werden gegangen und heuen dann halt einfach mal so in Hoffenheim an. Also schlimm genug, in Hoffenheim grasst ja eh schon den Jugendbereich ab. Und der VfB hat es ja eh schon schwer in diesem Bereich, weil vor 10 Jahren gab es halt Hoffenheim noch gar nicht. Und da gab es auch kein Nachwuchsleistungszentrum in Heidenheim und keins in Sandhausen und keins in – kein ordentliches in Freiburg und so weiter und so weiter. Also die ganzen – Baden-Württemberg hat der VfB alles abgegrast und dann konnte man schön auswählen. Und mittlerweile ist es ja anders. Und da muss man sich halt auch auf die Gegebenheiten einstellen.
Vielleicht das perfekte Stichwort.
Da wurde sowas von geschlafen.
Aber wenn wir da jetzt schon bei Hoffenheim sind, dann können wir – also ja, ein Brain Drain nennt man es ja glaube ich, Richtung Hoffenheim, aber umgedreht hat der jetzt ja auch stattgefunden. Und da würde mich mal interessieren deine Meinung zu Jan Schindelmeiser. Der war bei Hoffenheim von 2006 bis – ich muss gerade nochmal kurz nachgucken – 2010. Das heißt, er ist gekommen in der Saison, in der dann Rangnick in der Regionalliga aufgestiegen ist. Und er ging dann, als man eine Erstligasaison am Ende dann auf Platz 11 beendet hat. Aber das heißt, er hat quasi von der Regionalliga bis zur 1. Liga mit dieser krassen ersten Saison auch damals, die hat er noch mitbegleitet. Und dann war er – du hast es vorhin auch schon gesagt – von der Bildfläche komplett verschwunden. Mir war der Name quasi schon entfallen. Ich musste arg in meinem Hirn wühlen, bis mir wieder einfiel, woher ich den Namen kenne. Und jetzt stelle ich mir die Frage, was meinst du, für was steht er? Und was ist quasi der Gedanke, der ihn vorantreibt oder den er für den VfB Stuttgart hat? Denn je mehr wir darüber reden, desto mehr habe ich den Eindruck, vielleicht ist diese ganze Aufsichtsratsschiene und so, die ich aufgemacht habe, tatsächlich gar nicht so wichtig, sondern er könnte jetzt vielleicht nach Robert, nach Dutt, bei dem man das auch schon gedacht hat, vielleicht tatsächlich derjenige sein, der diese andere Kultur und der auch die andere Idee für den VfB Stuttgart hoffentlich langfristig nach vorne treibt.
Ja, die Hoffnung haben natürlich die meisten, aber das kann ich wirklich schwer einschätzen, weil da geht es mir wie fast jedem anderen auch. Dafür war er jetzt zu lange weg und man weiß ja auch nicht so ganz genau, was er da gemacht hat in der Zeit. Außer diese paar launigen Anekdot-Tötchen da, von wegen hier Oldtimer oder Autos zusammenschrauben und sowas, das interessiert er kein. Er muss ja was anderes gemacht haben, mit dem er Geld verdient hat, sechs Jahre lang oder fünf, ich weiß nicht wie lang es war. Insofern, da tue ich mich ein bisschen schwer. Also ich weiß noch aus seiner Augsburger Zeit, er war in Augsburg auch mal. Er ist schon einer, der eine klare Ansicht hat und die dann auch klar vertreten kann und auch beharrlich vertreten kann. Allerdings weiß ich dann jetzt nicht, inwieweit das gut oder auch für ihn zum Nachteil sein könnte in so einem Verein wie in Stuttgart, wo es ja dann doch offenbar sehr speziell auch bisweilen zugeht. Und da tue ich mich echt schwer jetzt da zu sagen, ja, so und so wird das jetzt dann in Zukunft machen. Es ist allerdings, um dann wahrscheinlich eine deiner Fragen noch vorwegzugreifen oder vorauszugreifen, schon anzunehmen, dass er sich in seinem Netzwerk jetzt auch erstmal umhören wird oder wahrscheinlich schon längst gemacht hat. Und da kommen wir dann halt wieder in Hoffenheim raus und bei so einem Namen wie Gisdol. Das hat er glaube ich heute auf der PKA schon, wurde die Frage gestellt, hat er gesagt, er will jetzt erstmal keine, nichts dazu sagen, nur so viel. Jeder weiß, dass er mit ihm schon zusammengearbeitet hat in Hoffenheim. Es wäre natürlich schon auch naheliegend. Und ich glaube, damit könnten einige auch ganz gut leben. Also was mir halt total fehlt im Zusammenhang mit Trainern in Stuttgart, Sonniger war ausgenommen und diese paar Spiele mit Stevens ist halt, dass da ein Trainer da ist, dessen Mannschaft man, wenn die jetzt nicht gerade weiß, mit einem roten Brustring rumlaufen würden, sofort erkennen würde, das ist jetzt eine XY Mannschaft. Also das ist jetzt eine Zorniger Mannschaft, meinetwegen, oder das ist jetzt eine Gistol Mannschaft. Und ich glaube, damit können sich die Leute besser identifizieren. Und so etwas, was wirklich einen stringenten Plan verfolgt, hat auf Dauer auch mehr Aussicht auf Erfolg. Und ich glaube, damit könnten die meisten ganz gut leben. Und ehrlich gesagt, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass Gistol da ganz ordentlich reinpassen könnte.
Er steckt ja auch so ein bisschen in der DNA von Stuttgart, oder? Also die jungen Wilden unter Magath, das magische Dreieck mit Balakow, Elber und Bobic, das waren zwar unterschiedliche Kategorien von Spielern, aber es hing immer mit einer offensiven Spielweise zusammen. Und ja, auch kann es noch weiter zurückgehen. Also das ist doch schon eigentlich so ein bisschen dafür stand, doch der VfB Stuttgart schon öfter, dass man sagen kann, für eine ambitionierte Offensivmannschaft.
Ich finde ja auch. Und wenn man jetzt nochmal aufs Leitbild des Vereins zurückgeht, ist er genau das, was da gefordert wird. Die jungen Wilden aus der Heimat sozusagen. Das ist ja das, was den Leuten da draußen verkauft wird, wie mir ist an mir oder echte Liebe oder sowas. Natürlich Marketing sprech, aber im Prinzip greift es ja genau die Themen auf, die es früher halt schon gab. Das ist ja auch völlig okay. Ich glaube auch, dass die Fans sich am ehesten mit sowas identifizieren könnten. Und ein letztes Mal jetzt noch auf Zornigga zurück. Genau, das war ja am Anfang der letzten Saison der Fall. Also der Fußball, der da gespielt wurde, der hat ja jedem gefallen. Die Ergebnisse haben halt gefehlt. Aber der Fußball an sich, das war ein klarer, ein klarer zuzuordnender Fußball. Kein Wischiwaschi wie unter Labbadia oder wer danach noch alles kam. Sondern da war völlig klar, das ist gewollt und so wird es gespielt und dann kommen hoffentlich die richtigen Ergebnisse. Aber das war ja dann nicht der Fall. Und das war jetzt auch eine Sache, die bei Luhukay einfach nicht gestimmt hat. Der ist halt ein Sicherheitsspieler. Das kann funktionieren, hat er ja schon oft genug bewiesen in der 2.
Liga.
Vielleicht hätte er es jetzt auch nur am Anfang so machen wollen, bis sich die Mannschaft ein bisschen besser findet. Aber immer nur über die Außen zu spielen, weil ich Angst habe, ich verliere den Ball sonst in der Mitte. Das kann es ja nicht sein. Also bei allem Respekt vor Mannschaften wie Heidenheim oder Sandhausen, aber die muss ich als VfB Stuttgart halt auch übers Zentrum knacken können und wollen und nicht nur jeden Ball mit Gewalt nach außen spielen, weil da tut der Ballverlust nicht so arg weh. Also das ist mir dann zu wenig.
Ja, vor allem in der Situation auch. Du spielst eben als Erstliga-Absteiger, der als der Hauptfavorit auf den Aufstieg wiedergeht und 2. Bundesliga ist sowieso schon defensiv ein anderes Pflaster als 1. Bundesliga. Und dann musst du schon ein bisschen variantenreicher sein, sonst wird das schwierig. Das siehst du ja gerade auch an Hannover, im Guten wie im Schlechten. Also sowohl Dinge, die funktionieren, als auch Dinge, wo sie sich ein bisschen verhoben haben.
Ja, gut, dazu vielleicht noch eine kleine Anmerkung. Es fehlen natürlich gewollt von Luhukay ein paar Spieler. Anto Gylgitsch hat noch gar nicht gespielt. Ein Sechser, den sie eingekauft haben. Stattdessen hat er einen Zimmermann da spielen lassen. Ein Spieler, der letztes Jahr mit der 2. Mannschaft in die 4. Liga abgestiegen ist. Manche sind nur verletzt, wie Ginczek. Wenn die Spieler da sind und fit und spielen dürfen, dann hat der VfB natürlich eine Bombenmannschaft für die 2. Liga zusammen. Dann führt der Aufstieg immer noch nur über den VfB. Aber das muss natürlich irgendwann auch mal zusammengreifen.
Das ist vielleicht der wichtige Punkt. Unter dem Strich kann man eigentlich sagen, wir haben jetzt ganz gut aufgearbeitet, wie das jetzt alles so kommen konnte, wie es ist. Und wenn wir jetzt einfach mal einen Cut machen und jetzt nach vorne gucken, dann sehe ich die viertjüngste Mannschaft der 2. Bundesliga, dann fünfjüngste, 24, 5 Jahre, der Durchschnitt. Aber auch wenn man sich die einzelnen Spiele anguckt, da ist wahnsinnig viel Potenzial auf vielen Positionen. Und im Grunde musst du jetzt versuchen, dazu den entsprechenden Trainer zu finden. Gistol ist schon eine Geschmacksrichtung, die mir als Außenstehenden sehr gut schmecken würde. Aber es gäbe auch noch ein paar andere, die da reinpassen könnten. Vielleicht auch mal jemand, den man nicht kennt. Es ist ja auch immer möglich, dass es mal jemand ist, der bisher unter dem Radar der Öffentlichkeit geflogen ist. Aber die Perspektive ist eigentlich doch – provokant gesagt hätte ich gesagt – durch den Luhukay-Rücktritt besser geworden für den VfB Stuttgart, trotz all des Chaoses.
Ja, wenn man die Gegebenheiten, so wie sie sich offenbar darstellen, als Maßstab nimmt, dann könnte man zu dem Schluss kommen. Das ist richtig. Auf der anderen Seite hat man halt diesen Aufstiegsgarantietrainer jetzt nicht mehr, den man sich ja ursprünglich versprochen hatte.
Ja, aber es kommt auch darauf an, wie du aufsteigst. Also, hört sich jetzt ein bisschen doof an, weil natürlich willst du erstmal aufsteigen. Aber Luhukay hat sich auch nie dann länger in der ersten Liga gehalten und der ist schon zweimal vorhergegangen, weil er sich von den entscheidenden Figuren im Verein nicht genügend unterstützt gefühlt hat. Das heißt, das ist jetzt auch kein ganz neues Muster für diesen Trainer. Und da sind wir doch eigentlich wieder genau beim Thema Nachhaltigkeit. Deswegen ist es doch vielleicht, selbst wenn du mit ihm aufgestiegen wärst, wäre es vielleicht kein in Anführungszeichen gesunder Aufstieg gewesen.
Am Schluss zählt halt das Ergebnis, das ist ja völlig klar. Aber die Bedenken waren jetzt wohl wirklich so groß, dass es gar nicht mehr funktionieren kann, dass man da jetzt einen erzwungenen Schlussstrich, wenn man es so nennen mag, ziehen musste.
Stefan, ich danke dir sehr. Jetzt hast du zumindest für mich hier viel Klarheit wieder reingebracht und ich merke mir vor allem, dass man sich das Spiel gegen Braunschweig in zwei Wochen dann mal unter dem Gesichtspunkt auch angucken könnte. Vielen Dank dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast und mich hier eingeführt hast. Stefan Rommel, freies Sportjournalist und bei Twitter als Ed Knallgürber unterwegs. Stefan, vielen Dank dir. Und das war er, ein Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Ihr könnt auch unsere anderen Formate hören, die Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz, das Tribügengespräch. Und in dem Sinne wünsche ich euch eine gute Zeit und dann schauen wir doch mal, wann wir demnächst wieder über den VfB Stuttgart reden. Bis dahin macht's gut, liebe Hörer.